okay well you clearly don't care so why
don't you just leave I would like to
stay this pertains to me I would like
you to leave why don't you go outside
and take a shot of insulin and have a
nap okay why do you always assume I have
diabetes you have a glass of apple juice
and tell me that you don't have diabetes
okay
see just the noise you made when you
stood up
[Laughter]
oh
you don't really toss the dough try to
destroy the old ways Gabe I will not let
you do it
[Laughter]
Return to Sender
clean up on L5
do you want your life to be better
or worse or to say the same get out of
my way
Danny
look at me
[Laughter]
could you please show them into
conference room B
I'll be right with you the
pharmaceutical meeting should be able to
move you know they should be able to
accommodate us
I thought he was going to show us a new
conference room B she took him with him
I thought she was talking to the
cameraman
camera lady
sorry sorry
no no it's great I love working at
Dunder Mifflin Taliban branch
oh
bloop
no it's great oh oh no it's great I know
we're going to dinner
we have three sex or heavy petting
closets one masturbation closet
does anyone have a problem with that yes
gay closet five
that's that wasn't the problem three
heavy petting closets one masturbation
closet and one gay club absolutely yes I
don't know problem everybody happy for
the glory hole
glory hole
[Laughter]
what happened to foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
have you seen
Michael hey oh
oh hey there you are
Michael
David guess who I'm dressed up sorry
one more time
you should have like I do I have the
lines right in front of me I know I've
painted them on the inside of my eyes
Muzzle you don't have to do this
wrong
oh God
it's hard to live this way I don't know
how you uh how you do it man you gotta
just just not care what people think
about you at all
come on baby you're welcome
[Laughter]
I don't know how you do it man I I can't
be so cold
you're baby you're welcome
not good
I don't know how you do it
I don't know how you do it do you
agreement you can live it buddy
you're not even enjoying it
not about the enjoyment it's about
curiosity do you have any other
characters oh I'm working on Scranton
Strangler
um
what do you think
[Laughter]
oh I'm working on a new one it's Grand
Strangler
oh I'm working on the Scranton Strangler
Starlight
I'm working
I'm working on a new one strand
Strangler
won't you smirk at me
okay
okay you know what Jim get your tongue
in your face
just let him flirt with her
no he's not gonna get anywhere and you
know he's gonna blow our sail who cares
it's not that huge a sale
Schwab
bam you know he's not gonna get anywhere
and you know he's gonna blow our sail
who cares it's not that huge a sale
the strong guy does
this here is a radon test kit okay I'll
be putting them everywhere and please
don't throw these out
this is a radon test kit
please don't throw these out
see them all over the office
[Laughter]
who is it
Who Is It Michael
you say hi
hi
I can sit on your lap you can sit on my
lap all you want because I am a male
Santa and that is something that Phyllis
cannot do oh my God okay it's really
comfortable
tell me what you want little boy oh I
don't know I didn't know you were gonna
ask me that what did you think was going
to happen I didn't know
no one's ever let me sit on their lap
before hurry up just say some toys
you give me some choices oh my God Kevin
please
I'm sorry
copper squat here we go sorry
I'm glad what would you like for
Christmas little Kevin
no
I didn't know you were going
well what
is going to happen here
[Laughter]
you know could you write down the name
of that Rehabilitation Clinic you
mentioned wow
foreign
[Laughter]
myself
oh man I'm sorry
we're gonna need a signal to bolt out of
there the slightest sign of danger okay
nut signal is lift your lips
let me say
no no no like this
oh no oh dude I'm so sorry
um
oh I'm so sorry dude okay
I think I'm gonna need some new pants
[Music]
clay get it on the DVD yeah
on the earthquake
you're so glad you all the Train's going
through Scranton
office hey there gorgeous how you doing
today
how's it hanging
listen
my name
you know what things uh
things I guess aren't aren't so bad
after all
okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
Phyllis we gave you one hell of a
wedding shower it was a golden shower
Phyllis we all gave you a gold
we all came in this room for your
wedding and gave you
we all came in here and gave you a
golden shower well where's my goldish
all right